all right chelsea chelsea uh where'd you
grow up where you from originally
virginia what part of virginia
pocahontas virginia
pocahontas oh i've been there
i just came back from there there's less
than 500 people
that was incredible yeah we just drove
through there i could do a whole story
just on that town
it's a ghost town now pretty much so it
was what was the uh
it was coal was your industry at one
time
yes because there's a downtown there's a
whole it's like an entire small town
with
with the grocery store and the all the
buildings and everything and it's
deserted
there's not a single business there the
post office and the bank
so the cold coal industry left and the
town is
it's just residents now yeah and nobody
works
how long ago you leave
i left 2000
and what was going on in 2012
my mom passed away oh i'm sorry she uh
she had cancer
she passed away at 43. i'm sorry
it's hard i just lost my mom too
you uh tell me about your childhood you
had both your parents when you were a
kid
my dad was in and out a lot
my mom she was always there
like my mom was my best friend
and you had siblings i had three sisters
and a brother
the childhood was good
i was raped from the age of eight to
sixteen
by my dad's dad your grandfather
did you ever tell anybody
it not until i was 16.
i'd had my first kid
he had colic bed and i was up for three
days with him and i thought
if somebody done this to him i'd kill
him
and i finally said something so who is
the father of your child
not my grandfather not your grandfather
and you uh
did did anything happen to your
grandfather after that he did four years
in prison i was like that's nowhere near
waiting
what he done to me right
it just seems unfair but
so you uh where'd your life go after
after that all
happened you had a child how many
children do you have now
i have three and three boys
well when my mom died
i was going through a custody battle
with my kids
and uh my youngest two's dad was
getting high i was always around it but
i wouldn't do it
but the day my mom died i did
i quit going to court for my kids
my whole life was to make my mom happy
when she died i didn't care anymore
so i left home i went to denver
for a year and then i went back home
for like two or three
see my sister and then this last time i
left i went back to denver
been in california going on three years
now so you went to
colorado and you left your children
behind
my sister
my sister's mother-in-law got custody of
them
and drugs were in your life at that
point for the whole period
yeah what's your drug then it was crap
and then i switched
to crystal but i haven't
the crack was my my drug of choice
like it took everything
you stay in touch with your kids
as much as my sister let me
and then how are you supporting yourself
when you were in colorado
uh i had a job for a little bit
at a hotel a prostitution
i haven't my kid's dad he would
do his little thing to make money but
when me and him split up i just
had a couple of pimps i worked for
and then when i got here i met
this guy named trey
he actually kept me from killing myself
you depressed a lot
thank you
what's the hardest part for you being
separated from your kids
that mama and your mom
like i'm the oldest out of my siblings
and all my other siblings took it hard
but not as hard as i did
like my youngest sister started going to
church
and i completely went in the opposite
direction
the sexual abuse you had when you were
young was that something your sisters
went through too
one of my sisters the one that's
like two years younger than me but she
told the same day it happened
and he uh
he had to be he got put on probation or
it was like nothing
and uh
the way my family treated her
i was like i can't say anything
where they how did they treat her like
my dad and
he was like you're a liar you're just
doing it for money
like we didn't get any money
to tell what really happened
like they said some really hurtful
things about her
so that made it difficult for you to
come out
and when i finally did that's the first
person i told was her
because it was i was like i'm sorry
that i didn't stick up for you
and now we don't even talk
the drug use helps you deal with it all
right
not necessarily deal with it but
not think about it not deal with it yeah
because whenever you come down it's like
it's 10 times more
than what it would have been if you
would have just dealt with it
so then you came to l.a at one point
how long you been here going on three
years
and you've been staying on skid row
do you have a tent no i finally got
an sro oh that's nice
but you were you were on the street for
a while yeah uh
i was in between
like with this guy i had met and
on the streets
it's hard for me on the streets
like people think i'm just
a pushover i guess and they try to take
advantage of me
i've been robbed
ah
i don't think i would be able to get by
if it really wasn't for the animals that
i've got
like they keep me busy
do you have any friends in your life now
a couple but not someone that i talk to
regular
regularly
just like if i see them pass by or
whatever
i'll talk to them but not real friends
do you have anyone that you trust
no are you here mainly just cause that's
for
the drugs are easy to find no
like
my favorite place is the beach
and like
i like the point that it's just like a
45 minute train ride and i'm there
like that's my like
when i go to the beach it's like nothing
else matters
but it took me
a minute to [ __ ] to get back
to even anywhere close to where i used
to be
like it just feels good to have my own
spot
so your your kids and your family are
still back in
pocahontas and going back there is not
i mean kids are there but nothing else
is there right
like the nursing home my mom was in was
at the end of my street
where do you like where would you like
to see your life go from here
i just started school again
i'm hoping to start some college classes
i eventually want my kids to come out my
hair
have you been clean before you have
i got queen for
like two two years
was it difficult
it was easier than i thought it would be
but like i quit
no rehab nothing but one day i was like
it was mother's day
and i was like and i gave it
all up again
it's been eight years since i lost my
mom and i still haven't
grieved over
my ex would tell me it's done it's
it's over with get over it how do you
get over it
yeah you lost a lot you lost your mom
you lost your kids
your town is even gone
i lost my stepmom since i've been out
here
but you're still hopeful a little bit
yeah that's great
i try to be i mean just taking classes
is a big deal it's a lot of work
it's like i can't remember anything i
learned when i was in school
what would you like to do with your life
i don't know if i want to work with
animals
or something where i'm pretty much
like by myself like some type of office
job or
i don't even know completely
you talk with your sisters one of them
the baby
she's 20
but i feel like our relationship is
slowly drifting away
ah
how old are you
29.
ugh
can you imagine going back to virginia
to pocahontas or would you bring your
kids out here
i don't want to bring them out here like
there's
nothing there anymore
the first thing i got to do is get clean
yep
because there's that way i want my kids
to see me
what do you think would help you get
clean
have you tried rehab no
no
i've said i was gonna do it a couple of
times
but i always had an excuse why i didn't
i think it might be tough
[Music]
uh
you